good afternoon on behalf of your back
enters the deans and staff of GS I want
to welcome you to the class day ceremony
celebrating the accomplishments of the
2012 graduates of Columbia's
post-baccalaureate pre-medical
pre-health program the Columbia postback
program is the oldest and most
distinguished in the country and it is
designed to push pommo and drive
students to levels of intellectual and
scientific discovery that they never
thought was possible post facts embody a
passionate commitment to healing which
they demonstrate through incredibly hard
work in their academic program and in
their many hours of hands-on volunteer
work I'm sure each post bacc resonates
with the experience of an 11th century
Muslim position and philosopher avicenna
who describes how he used to go home
every night set out a lamp and start
reading and writing and whenever sleep
seized me he writes I would see the very
problems I was working on in my dreams
but he adds I continued studying until
all of the sciences were deeply rooted
within me and I understood them as well
as is humanly possible an even more
famous 11th century Muslim position
known in Europe as Roz's laid out in
compelling fashion the moral imperative
underlying of ascenders and your drive
to immerse yourselves in the
Medical Sciences the supreme end for
which we were created he writes and
towards which we have been led is not
the gratification of physical pleasures
but the acquisition of knowledge and the
practice of justice these are two
occupations the quest for knowledge and
the practice of justice that are our
sole deliverance out of the present
world into the world wherein is neither
death nor pain I can think of no
individuals who better embody these
ideals of knowledge and justice than
those of you sitting before us today
your scientists but also humanists and
social scientists all dedicated to the
pursuit of truth and the alleviation of
suffering and like roses over a thousand
years ago you will face scientific and
ethical challenges that would overwhelm
most of us I'm convinced however that
you enter upon your careers as
healthcare professionals fully equipped
to engage and grapple with these
challenges I want you to know how proud
we are of your accomplishments and how
proud we are to count you members of the
Columbia family let me leave you with
other sinners most important piece of
practical advice which you should keep
with you throughout your professional
lives make sure he said to keep the
leeches for at least 24 hours before you
apply them now I would like to introduce
to your fearless leader Dean Victoria
rosner
Dean rosner will introduce today's
keynote speaker
Thank You Dean on hi everyone it's
wonderful to see you here all today I'll
be back to talk to you again later it's
my pleasure to introduce to you now our
keynote speaker dr. Robert klinsmann
some of you may already know dr.
Klinsmann as the director of the MS in
bioethics program in which a number of
our postback students take part he is
also a Clint a professor of clinical
psychiatry at the Columbia College of
Physicians and Surgeons and at the
Joseph mailman school of public health
as well as the director of the ethics
and policy core of the HIV Center we are
very lucky to have dr. clits menhir to
speak with us today in part because he
embodies a core ideal of the postbag
pre-med program that students with a
range of backgrounds and skills bring a
valuable diversity to the community of
healthcare professionals dr. klinsmann
in addition to being a psychiatrist is
also a noted writer an ethicist a
memoirist and a journalist with six
books and many many articles to his name
about his most recent book which just
came out and it's wonderful called mi my
jeans confronting fate and family
secrets in the age of genetic testing
scholar Katherine Stimpson has written
it is a gift to early 21st century
genetics the book shows how 64 different
individuals grapple with the unwanted
legacy of genetically linked diseases
such as breast cancer or Huntington's
other books of dr. klinsmann's deal with
topics ranging from HIV and AIDS to mad
cow disease to what happens when doctors
become patients I first encountered dr.
klinsmann's work when I read his 1996
book in a house of dreams and glass
becoming a psychiatrist in that work he
wrote with complexity and sensitivity
about the challenges involved in 21st
century psychiatry a practice that he
depicts as both continuous with the
fabled 19th century madhouse and
radically transformed from its origins
like many of our postback students dr.
klinsmann's road to becoming a
psychiatrist was filled with questions
and he lets us in on his process of
self-discovery in the most intriguing of
ways including this little snippet of
dialogue that he had with his mother
along the way she said to him won't it
get to be too much after a while talking
to crazy people all day and he replied I
think it would be interesting in
addition to his success as a writer a
physician and administrator as if that
wasn't enough dr. Klinsmann is a
decorated scholar who has received
awards including fellowships to
important writers colonies like McDowell
Otto and bellagio he has been nominated
for both the Pulitzer Prize and the
lambda literary award in 2006 he was
appointed by the governor of New York to
serve on the Ethics Board of the New
York State stem cell Commission he has
held visiting professorships at the
University of Virginia and the
University of Pennsylvania and he
attended Princeton as an undergraduate
followed by Yale University School of
Medicine it is my privilege to introduce
to you dr. Robert klinsmann
well thank you dean rosner for that
wonderful very generous introduction and
for inviting me to speak here today and
Dean on and distinguished faculty and
guests I'm honored to be here with you
and to all of you who are graduating
today congratulations you are entering
into wonderful professions at an
important time historically filled with
unheralded opportunities in expansion
but with those great opportunities come
certain challenges and I would like to
speak with you today briefly about both
those advances but also those questions
that I think you are uniquely poised
because of your backgrounds to address
as you know over the past 100 years the
growth of knowledge in the Health
Sciences has been unprecedented during
that time x-rays and
electroencephalograms electrocardiograms
ultrasound magnetic resonance imaging of
the brain in the body were all developed
the human genome the instructions for
making a human being was discovered and
largely decoded we have developed
effective treatments for wide variety of
common ailments antibiotics drugs that
reduce cholesterol and high blood
pressure diabetes and depression tylenol
for headaches we've developed vaccines
for TB yellow fever polio mumps
hepatitis influenza and other diseases
we regularly transplant kidneys livers
lungs hearts and even skin certain
diseases such as smallpox have been
entirely eradicated from the earth we
have literally saved and improved
billions billions of lives the future
holds further promises involving
personalized medicine in choosing drugs
and doses based on each individual's
particular genetics as well as stem cell
therapies in additional new medications
and ways of preventing countless
diseases you will see extraordinary
things in your lifetimes inventions in
other fields from the internet to cell
phones are also revolutionising how
health
professionals practice and communicate
with each other and with their patients
these achievements are also improving
dentistry veterinary medicine and
countless other areas yet particularly
in venison challenges also loom we live
of course in an ever-shifting world a
profound environmental economic and
political change our technology
breakthroughs have great costs as well
increasingly we as a society simply
cannot afford to provide all the
treatment that all people want at the
moment some 40 million Americans
including a millions of children lack
any health insurance whatsoever thus far
the fate of President Obama's plan for
addressing these gaps remains unclear
technologically we can keep millions of
people alive who are permanently in coma
and will never awake many people would
like to maintain these lives in part to
avoid wrenching decisions of when to
withdraw artificial life support
literally when to pull the plug several
years ago the president sought to
encourage physicians to discuss
end-of-life care planning and advanced
directives with their patients Sarah
Palin is you made two creeks all
denounce this effort saying they're
creating death panels to get rid of
granny the president took the suggestion
off the table which i think is
unfortunate such conversations are in
the best interests of patients family
members and our society as a whole these
issues clearly raise difficult ethical
dilemmas and as you go forth into your
chosen fields you will have to wrestle
with these and other conundrum daily you
will face quandaries which science alone
will not give you answers for here is
where however you were uniquely situated
and can in fact help in college many if
not most of you majored in disciplines
outside of science in the humanities and
Social Sciences and I would like to
encourage you to continue to draw on
these critical other fields
increasingly medicine needs input and
insights beyond those of science alone
science can solve many problems but not
all of the dilemmas we now face several
years ago I became a patient myself and
was stunned to see how much I did not
know as a result I ended up interviewing
75 other physicians who had also become
ill I wrote a book is mentioned called
when doctors become patients exploring
these experiences and what I found
constantly surprised me I always thought
I was Miss compassionate one young woman
with breast cancer told me that I
understood what my patients were going
through then she said I became a patient
myself I had no idea what my patients
were going through she said my eyes were
completely opened these doctors suddenly
realized all they had not learned in
pre-med courses and in medical school it
took becoming a patient for them to see
many of these doctors used to dismiss
for instance nonspecific symptoms such
as fatigue or nausea or even pain
instead they focused on the numbers lab
tests that measured liver functions or
other chemicals in the blood but now
they realized how important these other
symptoms were one gastroenterologist
told me that she had treated literally
hundreds of cases of abdominal pain then
she herself developed it in retrospect
resplendent had no idea she said that
when patients said that they had pain
that this is what they meant it was so
much worse than anything I ever could
have imagined listening to the language
of patients use to sense the meanings
behind the words and the limitations of
those words is key if you listen to your
patients and elderly doctor once told me
they will tell you what is wrong they
will diagnose themselves he has
generally been right but many competing
pressures will get in your way the
average doctor
patient visit is now less than 11
minutes listening for nuance an
inflection is ever more important in an
age of high-tech machines the best
instruments that you have will be your
ears and your eyes as doctors we also
need to pay it more attention to our own
language one elderly surgeon told me the
night before I had to undergo surgery he
said my surgeon came and said to me
there's a five percent chance you may
die tomorrow in the operating room that
night he told me I couldn't sleep only
later did he say did he realize that his
doctor could have instead said quote
there's a ninety-five percent chance
that everything should go okay and the
surgeon said to me do you know I've been
a surgeon for almost 50 years and I
never realized that those two bits of
information that are statistically the
same have such completely different
meanings to patients I had no idea he
had never thought about it now he does
yet here you here today have been
trained to think about not only science
but about this humanities and the social
sciences about language and meaning and
the broader social context shape our
lives and can limit what we see and I
think you can be more sensitive to these
issues and train your colleagues and
eventually your students to be as aware
of these issues as possible many many
other examples exist of how language and
meaning are vital in healthcare and will
be in what you do recently I also
interviewed patients who had or were at
risk of various genetic mutations
doctors tend to see genetic markers
associated with disease is either
present or absent either positive or
negative is the test like a pregnancy
test you either have a mutation for
breast cancer or you don't but what I
found is I described in the book am I my
genes that Dean rosner mentioned the
patient's I spoke with saw these tests
in much more difficult in complex ways I
always knew I shouldn't have stayed in
that terrible relationship one woman
said to me why is that I asked because
that's why I've breast cancer
but you have the breast cancer mutation
I said oh yes yes but what triggered it
was the stress of that horrible
relationship and I always told myself I
shouldn't have stayed in it as long as I
did another woman said to me I always
knew I shouldn't have stayed in that
awful job for all those years and lived
on Long Island that's why I have cancer
but you have the mutation I said yes she
said but the stress of that job and all
the high tension wires on Long Island
that's all what triggered it similarly
an african-american woman in the South
Bronx I interviewed said you know it's
all the crap that they dumped up in the
landfills of the Bronx they would never
dump in Manhattan where the rich people
live that's why I have cancer now all
these explanations may in fact be
correct breast cancer even with a
mutation may result from complex
interactions of genes environment and
behavioral factors but my point is that
patients come up with stories about
their illness to try to make sense of it
and to find order they construct
narratives that makes sense to them and
these can in fact and in fact determine
whether they decide to seek treatment
whether they decide to get testing
whether they tell family members who
might also have these muties genes about
these genes so doctors and patients look
at medical information very differently
and we need to understand our patient
stories and how they view the problems
they confront yet medical school pays
far less attention to these areas than
it should you who have had the privilege
to study the world from other
perspectives can and should listen for
these tales doing so will make you
better doctors you have something else
to that you can offer the fields you now
enter laboratory studies have greatly
enhanced health care but medicine
continues to need good research analysis
and debate about what we can and what we
should do and how you have been trained
here at a great university that values
inquiry at its deepest levels and i
encourage you to enter your new fields
with open minds then to help shape these
realms it will be easy and
tempting simply to see your work as a
job where you punch a time clock but you
can also work to improve the practices
and systems that surround you you can
write for professional journals or
elsewhere about the ethical social
psychological political and of course
scientific questions you face great
discoveries have been made by physicians
who think critically and do not accept
everything at face value who observe and
think about what they see in the 19th
century for instance lithium was first
used to treat gout it was not effective
but some doctors noticed that it calmed
patients mood it was eventually found to
be extremely effective for manic
depression more recently sildenafil
better known as viagra would develop to
treat heart disease it did not work but
patients began to tell their doctors
about its other effects a few doctors
listened and the rest is history my
point here is that you too will see
patients struggling with various medical
symptoms and side effects that have not
been described you will also see
homelessness hunger and effects of bad
social policies and you should bear
witness to what you see research it
write about it and help improve the
field if you see something say something
you can contribute often uniquely so and
should in these ways you can help not
only your patients but your colleagues
your profession future patients their
families and society as a whole yes we
live in an ever-changing world but you
each here especially can and should work
to make it better in these ways drawing
it on all you have been privileged to
learn enjoy the wonderful futures before
you and they are wonderful you're
entering exciting professions at
exciting times but you should also
contribute to them drawing on all you
have learned thus far good luck and
Godspeed thank you
good afternoon I'm Andrew sunshine
director of the postback program the
time has come to recognize the postbox
who have just completed the preposterous
Lee difficult allegedly impossible
pre-medical course requirements an
important milestone on the path to their
careers as healers I will presently
summon each candidate to this podium to
be congratulated by the deans or keynote
speaker faculty and also to receive
their alumni pins from Janet Griffin
Associate Director for alumni relations
but first I wish to pause to acknowledge
the faculty whose instruction has
brought our candidates to this stage to
this very stage let's show them but show
them our appreciation for their
dedication to learning and to our
students
before we return to our candidates I
have a request to make of the assembly
please please hold your applause and
your cheers until the last post back has
been cold to stand forth we want every
name to sound clearly as the candidates
cross the podium it is now my privilege
to summon each of the candidates to the
podium by name
ok
great here we go Rachel tally Melissa
ribble Laura record Oh Cara seagull
Robert berkey Simon barbae Carly lang
Alexander Myers Rio Beardsley Jillian do
good
Eli woke off Christina h chung bogus
lava dimitrova powell randy lee jonathan
penner Brian Cohen nuh Hallie nanavati
Elizabeth Daphne vertor Sarah Laurie
Phoebe priolo Carolina Thompson
Matthew wheeler Gabriella Aguilera
Priscilla da Silva Catherine Troy Adams
Weber Nicholas David free nuh johane
paul mccormack Daniel borin Brenner
Claire Machar lot Meredith men's
Felix zest love skee Emily sparrow Lee
greasy apparatus Florence who've read
Benjamin krippendorf you Mako kawano
Tiffany y g patrina Sexton Darcy all
would
Joshua Phelps Eric Sturgill Claire
Tobias Claire Audrey by an eight on
rossik Laura sorry Claire Louie Nicole
alum auntie Kira doom Whaley Constance
new Soros
Melinda espiritu Diana shoe Nicole inman
Stewart Davidson Daniel Stifler Mona
Griffin dawn Quigley Jessica Montes
Merete Perlman Shapiro a thief javed
aundrea glessner Natasha beard bound
Shannon philanderer Molly gresini
Chelsea Schmidt
milna roofin Alyssa shocking Liza whore
bar Jessica Epstein Nicholas white Ryan
Gratton yeh saali jun Ji Yi Oh Sylvia
Kim Oliver O'Connell Christopher
Hernandez John Andrews Christopher
Seaton gay tizian
amal Masri lai lai kwok I jun wang Adam
Schein
James Swanson jr.
guess so
well let's hear it for the graduates
now before I close I ask that the
candidates stand up again and turn and
face your families and friends and pay
tribute to them for accompanying you on
your journey in keeping steadfast faith
in you please clap
it is now my pleasure to introduce to
you my friend and colleague lymari got a
seal good afternoon I have the honor of
introducing our 2012 class day student
speaker Jillian Dugan is a 2010 graduate
of the University of Pennsylvania where
she earned a bachelors of arts degree
magna laude in international studies
with a minor in french and also earned a
Bachelor of Science degree magna
laude in economics with a concentration
in healthcare management and policy from
the Wharton School it was a fateful trip
to Senegal during her sophomore year of
college that would set Gillian on the
path to medical school soon after
completing her undergraduate studies
Gillian joined our program in summer
2010 as a postback student jillian has
earned praise from her faculty here at
Columbia for demonstrating excellence in
her academic coursework in addition to
volunteering her time and effort and
clinical and research settings jillian
has exhibited a strong service ethic by
participating in our student
organization the PMA as one of their
members at large Gillian exemplifies
what each of you bring to this program
perseverance integrity and the
commitment to serve the greater
community please help me welcome miss
Gillian Dugan
hello everyone welcome family and
friends it's so exciting to see you all
here to my fellow postbox
congratulations we made it through these
two years as Dean Castillo said my name
is Jillian do good and I came to the
postback program right after undergrad
at the University of Pennsylvania along
with Stewart and youth day I graduated
pen with two degrees a BS in economics
and a VI and International Studies a
minor in french and a concentration in
healthcare management some might call me
indecisive but i like to think that i
just really like school how did I end up
here you might ask my pursuit of
medicine began while I was studying
abroad in Senegal in West Africa during
my sophomore year of college often when
people ask me why medicine I tell them a
story of me crumpled on a bathroom floor
rolling around due to an intestinal bug
I got by eating street meat I say maybe
it took me getting sick to realize that
I was actually passionate about learning
why people get sick sometimes I tell a
story of me standing on the edge of a
cliff in Mali looking outward at the
vastness of the expanse before me I say
for the first time I recognized my place
in the universe and my opportunity to
make a difference in reality my decision
to pursue medicine was neither as lofty
as an epiphany on a mountaintop nor as
lowly as me crumpled next to a toilet it
was rather a confluence of many subtle
factors any one factor would not have
been a strong enough impulse to
stimulate me to pursue medicine but
there's some total is what matters my
parents love for science and for
Humanity my experiences working in
hospitals in research and in the health
care industry these potentials kept
building and building
finally the gentle prodding of my now
fiance pushed me over the threshold and
from there the floodgates opened as
Professor Fierstein taught us an action
potential was fired in me the action
potential has been propagated ever since
jumping from kinematics to chemical
bonds to evolution and aromatic rings
and now right now it is synapsing here
we have learned so much in the past two
years so much we as malva scientists are
like hitchhikers searching for the
answer to the ultimate question of life
the universe and everything I remember
in our first biology class professor
chasin told us that physics explained
all of the really big things in the
world chemistry all the really small
things in the world and biology all of
the things in the middle so much science
has been stuffed into my brain that
there is a point two weeks ago when I
just had to say stop my brain is full I
cannot hold any more information inside
coming to columbia has meant learning
from people at the tops of their fields
professor bruce who is on the shortlist
for the Nobel Prize every year taught me
gen chem one we had a Cabell of young
impressive faculty teaching us chemistry
from this group I would like to
highlight professor Schneider
how many Orgel professors get a standing
ovation at the end of class then again
how many Orgel professors play who wants
to be an orgo millionaire complete with
sound effects and lifelines we have
learned from professors Doubleday and
bute 'ok who have actually been teaching
at Columbia forever things thanks to
Professor beauty I will never forget
Newton's third law of motion this man
possibly in his 70s sat down in a
rolling chair with a fire extinguisher
in hand he pressed down on the nozzle of
the fire extinguisher and literally
propelled himself backwards across
classroom for every action there is an
equal but opposite reaction thank
goodness he was wearing a helmet finally
I could not talk about the academics
here without mentioning Dean valentini
and dr. maschwitz Dean valentini was
never my professor and yet I found
myself in his office hours week after
week trying to understand why acids or
acids trying to figure out what the heck
entropy is dr. maschwitz is an
institution in herself I have met
Columbia professors who still shudder at
the thought of her class
when I think of dr. maschwitz I will
think of bagels and cell junctions I
will think diuretic means to pee mostly
I will remember the panic attack she
nearly gave me during our final first
semester you see my father is the head
of hematology at Columbia Presbyterian
and his specialty is clotting disorders
when I saw the words hemophilia and
clotting factor written on the top of
the exam I thought oh my gosh I must do
well on this test I cannot shame the
family speaking of family I would just
like to acknowledge all of the family
and friends here today we could not have
gotten here without your support and
encouragement if the path through this
program was an action potential you
friends and family where it's myelin
sheath protecting us making sure we
finished with the same energy and vigor
with which we began to the parents thank
you also for producing such interesting
intellectually curious and compassionate
children for me this program was so much
more than what I learned in the
classroom and I think that this is
because we have such amazing people here
really amazing objectively so just check
the new york times article on postback
Molly gresini if you don't believe me
let me now give you a few examples of
these people I remember the day last
year when I was at home watching the
Food Network when suddenly I realized
that man on TV is my physics lab partner
Dave wherever you are thank you so much
for your Moroccan chickpea stew it got
me through one especially hellish round
of midterms also he's very good at
explaining things step by step and I
think his future patients will
appreciate this also through this
program I met Nikki my co member at
lights on the PMA I love working with
you you're mine say your mind is always
working only you could figure out how to
take down those crazy
tablecloths on a windy day at the same
time I am so inspired by your quiet
sense of duty for those who don't know
Nikki organized the postbag school
supply drive last summer why because we
as post bags have a lot of extra
notebooks and surely someone else could
use them or take Daphne Daphne teaches
cooking classes to psychiatry patients
she runs the community psychiatry
project she hosts parties for every
occasion and she does it all with the
biggest smile on her face never asking
for anything in return when I was
accepted to medical school this year she
sent me a box of a dozen cupcakes each
one personalized needing Daphne at
orientation actually totally changed my
outlook on this program my initial plan
was to keep my head down focus on work
and just push through these two years
until I made it to medical school but
her positive energy her generosity of
spirit encouraged me to open up and
embrace the people around me I never
expected to find the community here but
I did we learn together we struggled
together and then usually we drank a
beer together people often talk about
the competition here but what should be
recognized more is the level of
collaboration enter the library at any
time and there are groups of post bags
just working on problems together I know
that I can go up to any one of you and
ask you for health and you'll be patient
with me as it takes me 10 minutes to
figure out one simple question as Albert
Einstein once dated most people say that
is the intellect which makes a great
scientist they are wrong is character my
post back memories will be of the people
karaoke with the PMA brunches with my
girls watching a giant pink monkey sing
happy birthday the net going to
sacrifice long very long conversations
with Adam show ever
seeing the pride in Dennis's face as she
showed me photos of his newborn nephew I
cannot emphasize the power of community
enough when I was in Senegal I'll and a
phrase neat neat I gaara bomb the people
are other people's medicine we got
through this program because we did it
together and as we all continue to
become healers let us keep in mind that
we too can be healed through the bonds
that we form and the laughter that we
share thank you
Thank You Jillian for that wonderful
speech I'd like to close I won't keep
you too long but I'd like to close our
ceremony today with a few final words of
praise and encouragement for all of our
students who have completed the columbia
university post baccalaureate pre
medical program as well as devout thanks
seconding seconding our other speakers
to the families who are here and who
have supported our students to this day
I want to honor the extraordinary sense
of dedication and purpose that has
brought you to this moment you have
toiled sacrifice and probably even
sweated in response to a moment's
inspiration a moment that revealed to
you a vocation for healthcare you did
not allow that moment of insight to
remain an idle fancy or plan for some
day later on today we celebrate the fact
that you have reached an important
milestone in your journey toward careers
in health care I think are and I'm
afraid Molly I'm gonna have to embarrass
you one more time I think our own Molly
gresini did a superb job of describing
her experience of that journey to a new
york times reporter in an article
published last month so here is how the
reporter tells the story the transition
to the postback program has not been
easy adapting to a rigorous and
unrelenting course load of physics math
and science was at first a stretch
compared to writing the papers and
scripts that had dominated her time as
an undergraduate quote it was not how my
brain was wired Molly says still the
reporter continues she had a love of
science and figured out how to process
and memorize a lot of information
quickly after isolating herself in the
first year to focus on studies she has
since loosened up she has even found art
in chemistry class where she has
employed her drawing skills as Molly
says some of the compounds are really
beautiful
I imagine that at two o'clock in the
morning when you were studying chemistry
beautiful may not have been the first
word that sprang to your mind to
characterize compounds but now with your
final exams only hours passed for some
of you there may be time to begin to
recollect in tranquility and see some
beauty in it all I know that this is not
the end of the educational road for you
but a new beginning what I wish for all
of you is that the pride and sense of
accomplishment you feel today will buoy
you up through the challenges that still
lie ahead many of you came into this
program thinking can I really do this
can I have a career in medicine today
you can tell yourself I can I will never
let that faith in your self waiver our
faith in you certainly never will this
may be graduation but we will always be
here for you for advice for assistance
and for fellowship we will be calling on
you to mentor the generations that will
follow in your footsteps please stay in
touch with us and allow us to continue
to cheer you on and support you in your
sent to great achievement
congratulations once more to all of you
and now as the bit as the as the band
seems to be striking up a few notes and
the champagne corks are popping in the
back of the room I suggest we all
adjourn for the the rest of our
celebration to continue thank you so
much